all right as you may have heard we are
making massive changes here at the Rubin
report starting right now as I say these
very words we are officially creating
producing and funding the show ourselves
and when I say ourselves I don't only
mean my team but you too my crew and I
are leaving our comfy home at Ora TV and
going completely independent that's
right for now on this show about
critical thinking open debate and free
speech will be for you and fuelled by
you the fans it took us about two years
to get our first hundred thousand
YouTube subscribers and we've gotten
another hundred and ten in the last five
months we know that something special is
going on here you guys email me tweet me
and tell me this on the street every
single day and that was our chance to
really blow this thing out of the water
we're gonna be building a badass new
studio to create more content than ever
before and when I say we I'm talking not
only about myself but my all-star team
my incredible producer David who's also
a master chef Owen happens to be my
husband as well as our head of
production Amira who is a television and
digital video mastermind as well as an
editing machine and a craft beer
enthusiast we are a lean mean well-oiled
machine and have been working together
for over two years this is just the
beginning though and we can't wait for
what comes next with our new independent
production company we plan to bring
multiple episodes of the Reuben report
per week and so much more not only will
we do more interviews but we hope to
take the show on the road to be able to
fly in bigger guests launch new segments
and be totally free to make any and all
executive decisions on our own here's
where you come in we can't do this
without you literally we realize the
best way to share these ideas is to be
beholden to nobody but our fans you guys
have helped us grow and share our
message across the world
David Amira and I all voluntarily gave
up our salaries health insurance and
stability to make this dream a reality
but we genuinely can't do it without you
we found an incredible studio here in LA
and have an amazing opportunity to build
it out as we like now we need funding
for equipment
like lights cameras microphones mixers
and a video switcher to streamline our
production process and of course I need
you guys to help pay my team forget
about me
these two are incredible professionals
who could make a lot more working for
network TV they believe in me I believe
in them and I hope you guys believe in
all of us so how do you get in on the
action well we don't want to put our
videos behind a paywall but there is an
option for you to donate monthly so we
can continue bringing you great content
patreon is the perfect way of picking a
monthly amount you're cool with and
helping us expand the Rubin report we've
totally revamped our patreon page so you
can get plenty of great perks depending
on your level of patronage I know some
of you will be able to give a lot some
of you a little and some of you right in
between for real every dollar counts for
us not only to grow but to keep the
Rubin report on the air we've come so
far and really helped change the debate
but we're just at the beginning I know
what we need just to stay afloat what we
need to grow what we need to really
expand and what we need to take this
thing to a whole new level altogether
you guys are now directly involved in
making any level of these dreams become
realities by becoming a patron the
message is that you all send me from
across the globe are beyond inspiring an
absolute proof that ideas are the most
powerful force out there so if you hear
what I'm saying if you care not only
about continuing the work we've been
doing but making this so much bigger and
taking on the regressives and social
justice warriors by giving a voice to
the majority of you who feel as I feel
then head to patreon.com slash Rubin
report or click the link below and let's
do this